welcome to wildstar this is devspeak no
Hey look a disclaimer so today we're
going to talk about a feature we've been
very tight-lipped on up until now it's
an exciting one for us because it lets
us do things with gameplay that we can't
really do in standard leveling or elder
game content we simply call it
adventures adventures our five-person
simulations that take place in alternate
versions of zones you've already played
think of it as a
choose-your-own-adventure dungeon only
in an open world where anything can
happen each adventure has both a
leveling and elder game veteran mode and
because it's a simulation we're able to
create gameplay modes and mechanics that
may not exist anywhere else in the game
and adventures are crazy repeatable
you're making all kinds of tough calls
and tactical decisions and they kind of
matter like determine the whole rest of
the adventure kind of matter of course
enemy AI and random variation mix it up
even more take the high crest
insurrection adventure once you and your
buddies air drop in you'll need to
decide what tactic to use against the
Dominion maybe take the sneaky approach
creeping around to sabotage and
assassinate maybe you rescue the
oppressed farmers or just maybe you turn
them into an army to rise up against
their oppressors freedom different
tactics and choices have different risks
and rewards the adventure mal grave
trail is the ultimate example it's kind
of like old school oregon trail with no
dysentery while you escort your Caravan
you'll need to pick from roughly a
gajillion different routes gather
resources rest defend against enemies
and the elements and deal with some
unexpected gameplay encounters like
tiptoeing the caravan through a
vermin-infested minefield or building
tower defenses to fight off an ambush
some routes are more explore friendly
some are more Sedlar friendly your
choices make all the difference and no
two runs are the same how about a
gangster murder mystery where you choose
who to align with into to oppose boom
crime lords wipeout or a massive
strategic tower defense where you build
up and defend your horse check it the
siege of tempest refuge or a MOBA style
battle where you fight a randomly
selected group of enemy champions mmm
for the wild now this may be a
simulation but all that XP it's all
yours and based on your performance you
can get metals loot achievements titles
and more so you might want to give a
crap and just like a dungeon when played
during elder game in veteran mode you
can earn this sweetest could believe
elder game content with unique gameplay
mechanics branching stories and content
that plays out differently each and
every time you run it daddy likey well
that's all I can show for adventures
right now in the meantime feel free to
send us a message here and here in here
all three at the same time the desert
listen